[Musique]
bonsoir main 17 septembre bienvenue dans
le journal de la rédaction de tv 60,18
voici les titres
le lancement ce matin de
l'entrepreneuriat pour tout ce
dispositif porté par saint quentin en
yvelines et l'association les déterminer
forme épaules les porteurs de projets 14
vont bénéficier de trois semaines de
formation intensive et d'un
accompagnement jusqu'en décembre les
deux ans après la pose de la première
pierre il ouvre ses portes 600 élèves
ont fait leur rentrée dans le nouveau
collège de mantes la jolie cet
établissement qui se veut innovant a été
conçu par le département des yvelines et
l'académie de versailles
la rectrice charline avenel sera notre
invité l'occasion également de revenir
sur les premiers jours de classe et puis
après l'annulation l'année dernière le
festival électrique parc était de retour
à chatou ce week-end deux jours de
musique au programme de cette 11e
édition retour sur l'événement en fin de
journal mais avant de développer ces
titres la france va honorer son
magnifique l'une des figures les plus
emblématiques du cinéma un hommage
national sera rendu à jean-paul belmondo
ce jeudi aux invalides annonces de
l'elysée ce matin l'acteur s'était fait
élire lundi à l'âge de 88 ans une
carrière riche avec 80 films à son actif
bébé elle avait passé une partie de son
enfance dans les yvelines à
clairefontaine où il a vécu dans la
propriété familiale dans les années 40
et a était enfant de choeur dans
l'église du village
[Musique]
c'était donc la rentrée aujourd'hui pour
la première promotion du dispositif
entrepreneuriat pour tous au sein du
husky cuba guyancourt en partenariat
avec l'association les déterminer
l'agglomération souhaite aider les
entrepreneurs à se lancer à pérenniser
leurs projets dans ce contexte difficile
elle et précision d'antoine durant à
steam n'est pas professeur il fait
partie des entrepreneurs sélectionnés
pour participer à un nouveau dispositif
lancé par l'incubateur sky cube à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines gérant d'une
entreprise d'audiovisuel il reconnaît
avoir besoin d'être pour se lancer dans
le monde entrepreunarial de rejoindre
cette formation parce que j'ai déjà une
entreprise en fait j'ai une entreprise
en audiovisuel dans le cinéma
et du coup j'ai rejoint cette formation
parce que je me suis lancé il ya un an
dans ce milieu là sans aucune base de
sans aucune formation aucun
accompagnement qu'un entourage ce qui
fait que j'ai fait j'ai commis
énormément d'erreurs il ya énormément de
lacunes dont je suis conscient d'avoir
et pour moi cette formation représente
également l'opportunité en fait d'avoir
ce d'obtenir cet encadrement d'avoir les
les
vérités si on peut dire ça comme ça du
savoir des
des experts au total 14 entrepreneurs
ont été sélectionnés sur les 50
candidatures reçues ce dispositif
propose des cours collectifs et
individuels des sessions de coaching et
de l'immersion en entreprise une
formation mise en place par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et l'association les déterminer
on avait aussi envie de
dynamiser le tissu entrepreunarial nos
petits entrepreneurs et notamment ceux
qui sont éloignés
des réseaux traditionnels
d'entreprise et donc ça a été l'ambition
de notre partenariat avec les déterminer
cette première promotion on a la charge
de deux d'accompagner les trois
premières semaines des créateurs
d'entreprise de la formalisation à la
posture entreprenariale au développement
du projet et après on a un jour par
semaine d'ateliers on va venir faire du
renforcement on va venir faire de
l'individualisation
sur certaines thématiques pour les
entrepreneurs en tout cas moi ce que
j'ai vu ce matin c'est une des hommes et
des femmes qui sont extrêmement
déterminé la formation durera quatre
mois pour se terminer le 17 décembre
100 milliards d'euros pour redémarrer
l'économie française voici un en france
relance a été déployé en réaction à la
crise sanitaire pour les un an du plan
la préfecture des yvelines réunissait
partenaires et entreprises au cours
d'une cérémonie quel bilan dans le
département regardez ce sujet préparé
par nicolas landry
[Musique]
après deux ans de travaux le nouveau
collège de mantes-la-jolie a donc
accueilli ses premiers élèves situé au
coeur du val fourré il grommelé regroupe
600 jeunes issus de deux établissements
de la commune particularité un projet
pédagogique innovant tourné autour de
maisons référente le reportage de
mélanie poker
elle ne s'appelle pas poufsouffle
gryffondor mais l'idée est la même c'est
maison référente qui fonctionneront
comme des micros conseils de vie pour
les élèves cet établissement situé au
coeur du val fourré est un nouveau
collège on pressent effectivement on
aura besoin on a besoin maintenant et
besoins
dans l'avenir de prendre en charge les
difficultés des élèves leurs besoins
parce qu'on est pas obligé par les
queues des difficultés sur tous les
temps l'enfant donc le périscolaire et
extrascolaire le scolaire bien entendu
avec l'aide des partenaires qu'ils
soient associatifs municipaux après deux
ans de travaux l'établissement a ouvert
ses portes le jeudi 2 septembre pour la
rentrée 2021 avec 600 élèves répartis
dans 28 classes les collèges ses années
chez nés ont été regroupés on nous a
très bien accueillis on s'est tout de
suite senti comme chez nous dans un
collège est tout à fait normal je pense
que ce collège et bien il est beau il
est grand le film cafétaria il aurait pu
être retirés des maisons à mes potes et
où un collège pilote de par sa pédagogie
et qui pourrait voir d'autres
établissements créés sur le même modèle
un projet porté par le département et
l'académie de versailles pour un coût
global d'environ 32 millions d'euros on
a déjà un programme de construction
d'une dizaine de nouveaux collèges puis
au fur et à mesure du temps qui passe on
rénovera des collèges donc on va
s'inspirer des échanges que nous aurons
avec les enseignants de cet
établissement son inauguration
officielle pourrait avoir lieu en
novembre ou 2021 son nom pourrait être
dévoilée à cette occasion
et pour parler de ce nouveau collège
charline avenel et avec nous par
visioconférence bonsoir bonsoir
électrice de l'académie de versailles on
l'a compris charline à vienne un
établissement totalement nouveau avec
une pédagogie nouvelle le désir
d'apprendre la différenciation la notion
aussi d'engagement qui sont au coeur de
ce projet et le temps de l'élève aussi
qui recentre et au collège avec des
activités périscolaires associative est
ce qu'on est à un tournant en matière
d'éducation avec ce nouveau collège
c'est complètement un tournant parce que
ce qui se produit dans ce nouveau
collège c'est bien d'abord c'est un
bâtiment exceptionnel c'est très
monumental c'est beau c'est transparent
on a envie d'y venir il ya des espaces
pour les élèves bien sûr pour leurs
activités périscolaires des ateliers de
bricolage de sport mais aussi pour les
parents bref c'est du point de vue du
bâtiment quelque chose de totalement
nouveau et que nous avons décidé avec
l'éducation nationale
d'habiter complètement donc on a
transformé la pédagogie pour être à la
hauteur de ce très beau bâtiment parler
de cette pédagogie avec eux on l'a
compris aussi un projet partenarial avec
le département des yvelines justement
comment est il été formalisée ce ce
projet de nouveau collège comment at il
été pensé
alors je dois dire que le conseil
départemental nous a faits et a fait aux
élèves et à leurs familles un cadeau
exceptionnel et nous allons travailler
durant de longs mois sur la manière dont
nous allions habiter ce
cet établissement est donc on a
accompagné le projet on accompagner les
enseignants pour faire émerger leurs
projets par exemple il va y avoir un
projet sur mars par exemple alors entre
les différents professeurs et donc nous
ce que nous avons fait au sein de
l'académie c'est de faire mûrir faire
mûrir les enseignants les élèves pour
épouser ce cocon qui nous est offert on
a vu dans le reportage le petit clin
d'oeil à harry potter avec la création
de ces quatre maisons référente qui
seront équipés qui sont équipés même
d'un foyer d'un espace détente de
travail d'expression
l'élève pourra y organiser des actions
lancé des défis internes maison l'idée
s'est créé de l'émulation favoriser
aussi l'esprit d'équipé au sein de ces
maisons référente oui absolument alors
d'abord on est sur la réunion de deux
collèges donc favoriser des projets qui
vont mobiliser des élèves qui viennent
de ces deux collèges c'est exceptionnel
parce que ça permet un lien et un
collectif indispensable
et puis on va mélanger les élèves par
niveau et il faut s'imaginer que par
exemple on pourra lancer un défi en
mathématiques faire un concours de
mathématiques et que chaque maison
référente concours race qui légitimera
et leur donnera en dit d'apprendre et
développera leur sentiment
d'appartenance au sein de ces maisons
vous en avez parlé aussi la place-forte
fait autant et bien d'activités
périscolaires associatif qui donc le
temps de l'élève le temps de vie de
l'élève et
recentrer sur ce collège est aussi une
notion charline adèle c'est que le
collège est ouvert sur ce quartier du
val fourré dans lequel il est implanté
pourquoi aussi fallait-il et bien cette
notion d'ouverture sur le val fourré
d'abord c'était très important de
l'intégrer dans la ville de donner une
perspective de montrer que ce collège
mais pas fermé bien au contraire il vit
avec la vie avec ses habitants ya une
place pour les familles qui rentrent
très facilement dans le collège qui est
d'ailleurs monumentale et une cafétéria
tout de suite et qu'on dès qu'on
arrivait donc voilà dire que c'est un
lieu de bien prendre un lieu d'intérêt
général ouvert aux élèves ouvert aux
familles est ouvert sur la ville eh bien
c'était le corps même du projet pour
revitaliser donner les meilleures
chances de réussite aux élèves peut-être
que ça va inspirer d'autres collèges
dans d'autres académies françaises alors
site une ouverture qui s'est fait dans
un temps de rentrer un plus d'un million
d'élèves ont fait leur retour en classe
dans l'académie de versailles plus de
300 milles dans le département des
yvelines est ce que malgré ce contexte
toujours présent celui de la crise
sanitaire est ce que les événements se
sont bien déroulées ce que la rentrée
s'est bien déroulé dans l'académie de
versailles
s'est bien déroulé parce que nous sommes
sereins sur le contexte sanitaire
d'abord on connaît le protocole que nous
appliquons c'est le même que celui que
nous avions en fin d'année dernière donc
les équipes sont rodées les équipes les
élèves les professeurs sont sont rôdés à
ce protocole on est en route la
vaccination dont on parlera très
probablement et du point de vue
opérationnel tout ça se fait très bien
bref on est serein sur le contexte
sanitaire ce qui nous permet d'être
concentré sur l'essentiel et l'essentiel
est bien ce sont les apprentissages et
tout le monde est aujourd'hui
complètement centre et là dessus et
c'est ce qui explique que cette rentrée
se fait d'une manière donc qui se passe
qui se passe bien et vous parlez de la
vaccination vous avez d'ores et déjà
indiqué que les 800 établissements de
l'académie allait être liés sont liées à
84 établissements de vaccination centres
de vaccination il y aurait aussi des
opérations éphémère au sein même des
établissements scolaires ça s'est d'ores
et déjà déclenché vous le dites sur
l'académie de versailles que dans le
département des yvelines aussi s'est
déclenché cette campagne
absolument donc en effet 800
établissements qui sont liées à 84
centres la plupart du temps c'est des
ondes et classe les élèves des centres
de vaccination parce qu'on avait des
centres de vaccination très très
opérationnel celui de saint quentin par
exemple qui permet de vacciner deux
mille cinq cents personnes par jour et
puis par ailleurs dans certains autres
cas ont fait venir lorsque les distances
sont trop longues le centre à domicile
si je puis dire on a commencé les
opérations de vaccination dans les
yvelines dès la semaine dernière
vendredi à saint germain à saint germain
en laye et bien il y avait deux
premières opérations de vaccination est
donc voilà c'est une manière de nous
rôder et puis de générer un effet
d'entraînement pour lequel nous avons un
grand effort de pédagogie à faire pour
réussir à convaincre les élèves à venir
se faire vacciner et à chaque rentrée
j'en terminerai par la sa nouveauté une
d'ampleur pour l'académie en cette
rentrée 2020 vous étiez venu d'ailleurs
sur ce plateau pour parler de ce projet
qui se lançaient c'était début 2020
c'est l'ouverture du campus de
versailles qui est dédié au patrimoine à
l'artisanat d'excellence qui sera
installée donc au pavillon de la tête de
la grande écurie du château de
versailles pavillon de tête de la grande
écurie duché de grands du château de
versailles c'est un projet porté avec
ses y paris université la région ile de
france et c'est un projet dont qui
touche à son but puisque l'ouverture je
le disais c'est en octobre prochain
absolument un très très grand projet
orienté sur les métiers du patrimoine et
l'artisanat d'excellence vous savez
aujourd'hui ces métiers sont très grande
tension on a besoin de compétences qu'on
a besoin d'attirer des jeunes vers ces
métiers qui sont bas qui ont un très bel
avenir et qui ont d'ailleurs besoin
d'innover et donc le principe de ce
campus dans un lieu qui est complètement
unique les grandes écuries du château de
versailles et bien c'est de faire de cet
endroit et du domaine de versailles le
plus grand terrain d'apprentissage des
jeunes qui sont souvent le plus éloigné
de ces questions du patrimoine et donc
qu'est ce qu'on va faire et bien on va
former de manière très très différentes
on lance une année tremplin pour des
jeunes qui n'ont pas encore choisi leur
orientation et qui vont pouvoir être
coaché pendant toute une année et à
l'est voire d apprentissage de la
gastronomie et à l'ébénisterie et puis
deuxième chose on vient vivre une
expérience dans cet endroit où on côtoie
des entrepreneurs des artisans enfin un
troisième chose dans ce campus on donne
à voir en donne à voir les métiers on
donne à voir les talents donne à voir
les compétences et les oeuvres des
jeunes et c'est ainsi que ce sera un
lieu de rencontre par exemple pour les
entreprises pour venir chercher leurs
artisans leurs apprentis dans ce campus
et nous consacrerons très prochainement
un reportage sur l'ouverture prochaine
je vous le disais octobre 2021 pour pour
ce campus avec la visite très prochaine
du chantier de ce campus de versailles
merci charline anel d'avoir été avec
nous
la rectrice de l'académie de versailles
dans le reste de l'actualité a un
nouveau patron pour la sécurité publique
dans les yvelines julien de fer a pris
ses fonctions de directeur départemental
ce mardi au cours d'une cérémonie dans
la cour de la préfecture des yvelines
jusqu'à présent il était le contrôleur
général des services actifs de la police
nationale et le chef d'état major à la
direction centrale de la sécurité
publique à paris je viens de faire est
nommé pour trois ans renouvelable une
fois
retour le week-end dernier avec un
rendez vous traditionnel de la rentrée
les forums des associations c'est
l'opportunité pour retrouver ou faire la
rencontre de ses adhérents après deux
années difficiles dictées par la crise
sanitaire le moment est donc à l'espoir
comme vous allez le voir dans ce
reportage à maurepas est de mélanie poké
et de patrick jacques de dixmude
retrouver des liens avec leurs adhérents
c'est l'un des trois sujets d'inquiétude
des associations qui ressort d'une
enquête le 8 juin dernier du ministère
des sports cette année on sent qu une
petite pose plus la question
parce que l'année dernière a été
extrêmement chaotique je crois que c'est
80% des cours qui ont été annulés donc
c'était une charge enfin ils ont payé
pour rien c'est pour ça qu'on a décidé
de faire un geste quant au niveau
financier et de réduire de plus de la
moitié les cotisations pour les anciens
certaines associations ont pu profiter
de la vitrine des jeux olympiques à
elancourt maurepas handball les
médailles d'or des deux équipes de
france font leur effet sur les
catégories jeunes effectivement 10 et
moins de 12 on a beaucoup on a été
beaucoup sollicités on arrive
aujourd'hui pratiquement au maximum de
d'adhérents qu'on peut accueillir sur
ces catégories là l'effet coli dont le
ressens un peu plus sur les catégories à
partir de 16 ou 18 et seniors pour
effectivement
le pass sanitaire peut amener de la
perte de licenciés puis d'une centaine
d'associations s'est rassemblée sur les
deux jours du forum mort d'asia 3000
visiteurs étaient attendus sur ces deux
jours par rapport à ce qu'on avait perdu
voilà un an on a vu un retour
significatif sur les deux jours mais je
pense qu'on pourra faire de bilan
complet
car la fin du mois de septembre contre
les associations ont démarré leur
activité sur le début de l'année 2000 21
50% des associations franciliennes
estiment que leur situation générale est
difficile
l'édition 2020 avait été annulé en
raison de la pandémie l'électrique parc
était bien de retour les 4 et 5
septembre sur l'île des impressionnistes
de chatou deux jours de musique électro
qui ont trouvé leur public sur lesquels
reviennent mélanie poké et patrick
jacques de dixmude
25000 spectateurs répartis sur tout le
week-end pour l'électrique parc château
à bouger au rythme de l'électro pour ce
week-end de rentrée après une annulation
en 2020 le festival a vu le public
répondre présent pour faire la fête
c'est génial de meilleurs festivals ça
fait deux jours que je sais pas
moi moi je suis en 2019 j'ai prié pour
2000 voyelles qu'ovide ça fait du bien
on sent on respire on est tous content
j'ai la voix cassée comme yahia el kobbi
napoléon qui vraiment c'est génial on
adore ya plein de monde c'est trop cool
la festivité les personnes qui sont là
la bonne ambiance jazz la musique et hop
je suis venu pour la musique mais pas
une bonne ambiance c'est ce qui fait la
différence la liberté
m
on a actuellement en ville une situation
qui est assez difficile et aujourd'hui
on peut dire s'inquiète trop bien on
s'est fait contrôler pas sanitaires
créée en 2010 l'électrique parc a repris
place sur l'île des impressionnistes en
ce premier week-end de septembre
pour cette nouvelle édition 80 artistes
se sont succédé sur les cinq scènes
c'est vraiment découvertes musicales
sont l'inde plein d'horizons musicaux et
puis elle la galaxie la grosse
caractéristique c'est quoi c'est ce que
j'aime ici à l excès de et des artistes
avant qu'ils soient connus
et
donc ça me permet aussi de programmer
les équipes avaient choisi de doubler le
plaisir pour l'organiser sur deux jours
une formule qu'elle souhaite voir
pérenne pour les prochaines éditions
et de la musique toujours pour refermer
ce journal avec la finale de versailles
live le tremplin pour les jeunes
artistes revient ce vendredi à 20 heures
sur le parking de l'europe quatre
groupes finalistes seront sur scène
telegraph vernis rouge et docks et
cazalet jo petit aperçu de ce qui vous
attend
arrivés premiers repartir
europe
je leur lève mon
[Musique]
e
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve dès demain
pour une nouvelle édition d'information
locale belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]